but how are you like just dealing with
the loss man obviously i'm sure it's
every day is different right mentally
i'm just busy hey i don't stop i wake up
i go to sleep at dinner four in the
morning i probably wake up at 9 8. you
know what i'm saying huh
back as soon as i wake up back in the
studio or playing the beat or just
innovating you know saying i wake up
waking these up like what are we doing
here i'm saying like how we finna do
something we gotta do something today
like what's the plot like do you feel
like um
just having like that high workout it
kind of helps you keep your mind off of
the effects off your bro cause if i like
and then every time i look up just [ __ ]
damn everybody do everything because of
him so you gotta say every time i look
up and see something i'm like damn
that's correct that [ __ ] really started
that [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
because he innovated a lot of [ __ ]
and he was like the spokesman yeah man i
saw um
i believe is your mom that was putting
the lawsuit together yeah wrongful death
what's the update with that i don't know
just waiting kobe it was kind of slowing
[ __ ] down right right right right right
right yeah man well [ __ ] bro i feel like
you've definitely done a great job of
keeping the truth alive
keeping it going man
and i feel like when you rap like people
you're you know you're you're your
brother's brother no cat and uh gene
it comes from the same field like you
know i'm saying most people don't
understand like they but i know you
sound like draco no like we literally
made this [ __ ] up together yeah
he was just popping first not me
it's still the same slang like you know
i'm saying it's all
if he make a word up or i make a word up
or catch you make a word up it's all the
same like you understand come from the
same it's just whoever put on the song
first
yeah i mean i told this to his face
multiple times that that's on video that
like just in terms of like uh a lot of
what's going on especially when he went
to jail a lot of people got got on with
his style so okay so basically la rap
usa he brought the flu flaming nervous
music i brought like the
the
pimp
slash finesse [ __ ] music like you know
what i'm saying i talk like more about
like
you know i'm saying like
jigging [ __ ] with juice and
pills and [ __ ] and like selling [ __ ] for
the high or just getting money from a
[ __ ] from perky meat and getting back
besides with [ __ ] jurgens and he more
like
flew flamma up if he
staring at my jury right right lean
bopping chili for chili baba like you
know saying like he more like
artistic with it i'm more like i just
say what it is you want some player [ __ ]